20e anniversaire de protection l'actrice
oscarisée dont l'actrice nommée giscard
et macho man de l'acteur oscarisé samuel
l jackson et lille est nommé aux oscars
james holland
[Applaudissements]
certains acteurs restent dans la peau de
leur personnage pendant tout le tournage
et certains n'arrivent pas à lâcher
drôle peut-être qu'on pourra se payer un
milkshake à 5 $ tout à l'heure ouais et
un royal cheese
voyez ce que je veux dire pôle fiction
c'était un chef-d'oeuvre et ces deux là
pensent encore que c'était le battle de
danse le sujet principal
etienne c'était bien plus que ça
s'écoute pas tout même qui se balade
dans la rue et elle se souvient encore
des répliques
le coeur du film c'est ce que contient
cette mallette comme tu y vas je
t'écoute
tous les meurtres et la boucherie
pendant 2h45 citées pour ce qu'il y
avait là dedans et à la fin du film on
n'en sait pas plus ce qui laisse le
spectateur obligé de réfléchir au sens
de l'existence
tarantino qui tu as écris cette
république tu sais tu devrais donner une
master class b écoute je le fais déjà
voulais voir ce qu'il y avait dedans
oui
les nommés dans la catégorie meilleur
acteur sont